lucy's story is my favorite
it always has been at its core this is a
love story
it's a story of a woman's courage who
would do
almost anything to save her husband's
life insanity
[Music]
lisey is a different thing for me
it's very close to my heart i
had pneumonia around the year 2000
and came really close to stepping out
when i came home from the hospital my
wife had
cleaned out my study and i thought to
myself
i've died i'm a ghost
and the idea from lucy's story came from
that particularly the idea that
writers when they make things up they go
to a different world
i wanted to tell the story that was in
the book but i wanted to make it better
i thought if somebody was going to mess
it up i used to tell my wife nobody's
going to mess it up but me
the story of scott's childhood when he
finally tells it
is particularly horrific
he retreats into this fantasy world
booya moon is a secret place it's a
place that's very very beautiful
and at the same time very dangerous
it's a very scary story in a lot of ways
it's scary in a supernatural way but
it's also scary because
there really are dangerous people out
there
easy story could only have come from the
mind of stephen king it's beautiful
and haunting and romantic and horrifying
what i think on this story i can think
on stephen king
and how is this connected with his life
it was a lot of pressure too
we wanted to make sure that we did him
justice and that we did the story
justice
i'm a visual writer i'm interested in
the power of the imagination
we can talk about it as otherworldly and
fantastic he's like oh no
it's real it's real
you